10h dans l'hémicycle du palais de la
source l'heure où le nom du nouveau
président du département est sorti des
urnes
cyrille melchior devient le douzième
président de la collectivité
je serai un président fidèle à mes
convictions au service des plus démunis
j'ai eu le soutien comme vous l'avez vu
de madame nassimah dindar qui a impulsé
une politique d'innovation sociale
je vais poursuivre dans cette voie parce
que je sais que la réunion souffre et
que le département doit rester au
service des plus démunis donc l'élection
du président qui a laissé place à la
désignation des élus de la commission
permanente 13 vice présidente était
désigné matière le cas on s'inscrit dans
la continuité de la plateforme et du
projet que l'on a monté ensemble il n'y
a pas de changement
bien sûr le président va apporter sa
touche le premier vice président mais on
a une ligne directrice ont un cap qui
étaient fixés nous devons être vraiment
au travail le plus rapidement possible
l'équipe est maintenant en place autour
de cyrille melchior et surtout ce que je
voulais dire c'est un grand bravo aussi
à madame nassimah dindar pour tout le
travail qu'elle a fait toute la
politique qu'elle a mis en place et que
nous allons continuer à travailler
jusqu'en 2014 une élection qui s'inscrit
dans la continuité tout en rendant
hommage au travail accompli par nassimah
dindar